nassimah dindar présidente du conseil
général était en déplacement à saint
paul elle a été accueillie par le maire
et toute son équipe à son arrivée un
accueil en musique et en danse avec
l'académie des dalles et leurs rimes
vivrait h et une visite pour la
présidence placée sous le signe d'une
mutualisation des moyens de la
collectivité c'est de la commune de
saint paul il s'agit également au
travers des conventions de permettre
l'émergence de projets en direction des
simples polos le devoir et l'obligation
nous les et de voir comment on doit
mutualiser
il faut mutualiser et optimiser nos
politiques
c'est ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
entre la commune de saint paul et le
conseil général
parce que nous signons une convention de
partenariat sur l'action sociale que
nous mettons en place
qu'il s'agisse du logement de
l'accompagnement de la jeunesse puisque
nous avons travaillé également là dessus
sur la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales l'accompagnement
également de la petite enfance des
parents qui cherchent une crèche une
assistante maternelle ou même l'accueil
familial où nenê ou tuer moment tout
cela est pur escape à sa propre personne
pour garder la paix familiale peut se
faire chez des personnes dont nous
optimisons
nous mettent ensemble pour aller plus
loin et pourtant
pour joseph sinimalé saint-paul doit
avoir de l'ambition et son territoire
doit se développer
nous avons tous les au projet
d'aménagement initié pour l'ensemble des
impôts il faut compter dans les 25
millions d'euros pour l'investissement
du conseil général sur la ville de saint
paul il y a les routes départementales
il y aller musée de villèle il y à la
forêt domaniale de maïdo ben hilli à
tous les demandes départementale qui est
très important sur le territoire de la
commune de saint paul il ya le parcours
de santé
donc moi je crois pas que le conseil
général est un des partenaires
privilégiés comme le conseil régional
pour faire évoluer et
les actions que nous devrons mener à
travers la population et pour la
population et avec la population de
saint paul des projets du développement
les aussi des projets en direction de la
jeunesse à l'image de l' académie des
dalons qui a ouvert ses portes dans
l'île de sainte paule des jeunes en
rupture qui ont pu remettre le pied à
l'étrier et mettre en place un projet de
vie
ces derniers ont reçu en écusson la
mairie de saint paul qui a signé une
convention avec l' académie des dalons
pourparlers l'utilisation par les jeunes
académiciens de certains équipements
sportifs de la ville
il a été aussi question du plan
départemental de parrainage de 4000
jeunes initiée par la collectivité des
parrains et leurs filleuls ont témoigné
de la richesse de ce dispositif pour les
jeunes pas se cantonner dans une
administration et à l'institution et ce
sont un petit peu des fois larvée entre
guillemets et tout d'abord
être près de moi quand j'ai besoin et je
voudrais remercier référant aussi
monsieur gaz je suis ravi que madame la
présidente est mme issus de ce type en
place et j'espère que dans ce dispositif
que je veux avoir un projet
professionnel
joseph sinimalé qui souhaite par
ailleurs que soit construit un collège
au moc feuilles
il souhaite que la collectivité
l'accompagnent dans la création d'un éco
village à village